so welcome back to the iced coffee hour
with you with your host gram Stephan and
Jack Jack welcome this is our ninth ever
episode good and for those who are
curious we have made oh go ahead take a
guess you know what today I actually
just looked I know but
oh wait total yeah total oh you know
what today's ad revenue didn't post yet
so I think we're at twelve twelve
hundred dollars I believe it is that's
exactly right
well hundred dollars yeah there we go
vodcast is doing swimmingly what are you
gonna do with all that money
what kind of Lamborghini do you want I'd
probably get an adventure yeah we'll
call it hot pink hot pink I'm probably
gonna get the svj roadster okay with
just the oh you said you like that one
it's just a carbon-fiber body the whole
thing so I'm gonna use the the podcast
money to go ahead and buy that on lies
investments in a lease I bet that thing
is probably gonna cost about $8,000 a
month to lease so we could get with us
and talk like 1,200 bucks we can get
like a few days of a lease that's not
yeah that would make a killer podcast
episode without Boyd's so let us know
guys know geez actually if you wanted to
rent it by the hour I bet it's like
$1,000 an hour are you kidding me oh
yeah oh yeah because oh we forgot the
downpayment of the road sources it cost
the MSRP of the car about five hundred
thousand maybe five fifty and it's a
thousand dollars an hour if you're gonna
rent it you gotta like Enterprise rental
you can't go to Hertz anymore yeah so
yeah but yeah if you're gonna rent one
of those car their expenses that's crazy
this is company thanks so much money
they make so much money doing that yet
is catching up on everything have you
been reasonably good anything exciting
happen in the life of Graham yeah the
algorithm is finally back in our favor
yes I feel so much better now
last week isn't such a run it seemed
like all the videos I had posted just I
don't know the algorithm just didn't
didn't like me last week and in a bit
the week before that it's like no matter
what I posted two weeks now no matter
what I posted it was just like 9 out of
10 10
10 I was feeling so discouraged and now
the videos have picked back up
thankfully the algorithm is coming back
in our favor so I'm feeling so much
better about things
YouTube has an algorithm like you said
it ranks lost 10 video so now we're
gonna be able to see when we get 10
videos how our videos perform relative
to the last 10 mm-hmm and when you get a
10 out of 10 it means of your last 10
videos that you posted you that went did
the worst and yes and and you know if
you have a 10x you feel bad on purpose
oh you know when you have a 10 out of 10
it's you feel like you failed like you
really questioned everything did I was
like my career is over
like I'm gonna I'm gonna have to go back
to work yes yeah let's do something else
on damning celebrities dinner any of
them respond Graham I was dying to know
one person responded back now is the
time that you got to put an ad break is
it me like the person who respond it is
right I wouldn't comment right now we'll
give you three seconds comment who you
think responded okay great
so Adam 22 okay yeah and what do you
respond he just responded back a little
like emoji so that basically means he's
acknowledging that you're in his inbox
yeah basically like I do that every now
and then if someone gets back to me and
I know I should respond to the person
but there's really not much like I don't
want to respond like a paragraph and in
acknowledgment usually is good enough
yeah cuz then I've seen it what I'd seen
your message I read it respect it
respond back but it ends there Adam 22
yeah so thank you in that
one-in-a-million chance he's ever
watching this yeah right on yeah for
those of you guys who are curious the
ring goes to press shot underscore K
underscore job oh gee it's a little
thing there oh yeah yeah for sure hahaha
thank you for entering there was 82
people that wanted it Wow 82 82 people
so I just did a Google sheet so listed
Wow
random number generator Prashant won wow
that's cool yeah it's a good way to do
it congratulations
we have pressing news okay what's going
on with the Bitcoin scam Oh Twitter wow
that was crazy absolutely crazy some of
the biggest names so yeah so what this
is is when they when they hacked into
all these Twitter accounts
it was like this this stupid Bitcoin
giveaway and it just says I'm feeling
generous today I want to give back
everyone say give back so if you send me
one Bitcoin I'm gonna send you to
Bitcoin back yeah
and they made like really famous and
yeah notable people tweet that right so
yes it was like Elon Musk yeah Kanye
Kanye Jeff Bezos Bezos Gates I think I
built back okay
Obama mama Jo bite like some of the
biggest names and I'm shocked that they
can hack anybody you're anything and
they choose to do a Bitcoin scam so I
only thought it happened to one person
and I figured that someone just found
out that password but this was like a
leak air like a crack in the security of
dinner because it happened to like seven
people I think there's so much more they
could have done with the access to their
accounts that maybe could have gone
unnoticed for a lot longer and could
have done either more damage or for more
money now here's the thing I mean some
people might say like this could be like
a political thing gonna hack in the
people just wanted money yeah so they're
all just about money I think I read a
source that said they got about a
hundred and fifty five thousand dollars
in Bitcoin in ten minutes which is which
is significant one hundred fifty five
thousand dollars in ten minutes is a lot
but you have to think it's like the
amount of work and skill and
sophistication it would take yeah I do
you want some help I just cut my
fingernails thanks yeah but the level of
sophistication it would take to hack
just for that was you know that doesn't
seem like it's worth it doesn't seem
like it's worth it and so like I was
thinking okay maybe it could be like a
test of something for something bigger
like they know now you wouldn't waste on
Bitcoin see it for a hundred fifty five
grand there's no way like something
better would be like its Twitter gonna
do about it I don't know they're
probably they're going to investigate
they're going to apologize you're gonna
do better next time that's what they're
probably gonna do just really what
anybody could you try it they're gonna
try to find it but if I mean if it were
me and I was like hacking
these places like first of all I'd want
a job so I'd go in and be like you know
I want I want $750,000 a year I want to
be a part of your cybersecurity team
like let's work together you know I
found I found inefficiency I'm really
good at this why are these people going
for Bitcoin it seems like if you have
that skill then it should be like worth
much more than $150,000 because I mean
that never happens
it's like hench lee jail time I mean
they're not gonna find a girl let's be
real you're not gonna find out who did
it unless someone rats your eye like
there's no way they're not gonna know
but I'm you know it would be a lot
easier to to tweet something about like
well I guess it was after I would wait
you would you would wait like during
morning hours of trading and you pump
stocks I mean you just mentioned some
little penny stock nothing's gonna soar
like three four hundred percent Elon
Musk says something like I'm gonna I'm
investing everything in neo yeah imagine
that like you know I'm we're buying out
neo at $50 a share seconds that thing is
gonna rise and and if you have any
amount of money
iDVD puts quadruple you're very quickly
and how would they like especially if
you knew you're gonna do this as I'm you
buy in like a month or two before keep
your position in there as you see it go
up start doing like you know just
selling off bit by bit by bit but make a
lot more money than just Bitcoin scams
but then it's traceable then they find
out like then they look maybe the SEC
looks at everyone who made like profit a
lot of money but but that would it would
be so a lot of people were trading me oh
there's so many people you think they
would so now if you did it if you I mean
I'm sure if you if you know that much
and you you probably be a very
calculated operation if you're gonna
join why pick why Bitcoin yeah and do
that it seems like just a very low-level
thing to get $150,000 just baffles me is
expected it would have been much my it
would be the equivalent of someone
breaking into like like an art
dealership do our dealership this would
he call it like an art museum and his a
Mona Lisa that you could steal like a
whole bunch of other stuff but you steal
something from the gift shop yeah and
like you broke in yeah the museum and
you had access to every every no one was
there no security yeah speaking about
all these celebrities and Elon Musk he
is
selling property on Mars right is he I
think so oh I think selling property and
I already was selling property on Mars
and I heard it was twenty-nine dollars
an acre sky via skim there's no way
someone has the rights to sell property
on Mars are you sure yeah there was a
guy a while ago who claimed that he had
ownership of the Moon you guys can look
this up it's real thing and he actually
fought it because he claimed like there
there's something about the moon being
like neutral territory but he did
something that like circumvented the law
he found some loophole where he was able
to file something to had the ownership
of the moon and no one responded to it
or contested it within a certain time
frame and yeah he like illegally got
ownership of the moon but that doesn't
make any sense because what was he based
in like America yeah because some like
that then he would have to assume that
America has the right to give away I
said what it was exactly I can we get up
rather than I've been here like I could
look it up it was it was a real thing
yeah it's this guy says meet the man who
owns the moon a loophole in a United
Nations Charter has allowed Dennis hope
to sell plots on the moon for more than
30 years in an early 1980s hope then
unemployed for about a year
thought he'd be a good property owner
and could make a living managing real
estate he looked out the window and saw
more unclaimed property than he could
possibly fathom the moon and he took a
political science course in college the
1967 United Nations outer space treaty
said no country could own the moon but
it says nothing about individuals hope
wrote a letter to the United Nations
saying the moon was his and he asked the
group to come up with a legal reason why
an individual could not claim ownership
of the moon he never heard back
I sent the United Nations a declaration
of ownership detailing my intent to
subdivide and sell the moon and have
never heard back there is a loophole in
the treaty it does not apply to
individuals since then he sold more than
six hundred eleven million acres of land
on the moon individual one acre lot sell
for $19.95 and there are discounts for
larger plots you once told a country
size plot of land 2.6 million acres for
two hundred and fifty thousand dollars
he sold plots in the moon to three
former presidents
George Bush Jimmy Carr Jimmy Carter and
Ronald Reagan
he's President of the Galactic
government a Democrat Republican
Democratic Republic he represents
landowners on the moon on some of his
other properties he claimed ownership of
Mercury Mars Venus Jupiter
he claimed oh yeah well he's at it
customers combined and the entirety of
Pluto for $250,000 Wow
that's insane yeah I love how he just
sends in like he's just like yep the
moon's mine now
like he said his intention was to own
claim ownership of the moon so and he
also contends there's more than six
quadrillion dollars worth of helium
reserves on the moon that he that he and
his property owners which there are
thousands on all of it helium-3 is used
in nuclear fusion and trades are about
$125,000 an ounce might be interesting
to buy a plot would you buy any moon
honestly I'd spend like a few in a box
and I just it just gets like as you
never know like in case this case this
guy turns out to be legit one day I want
a piece of that oh how I bought the moon
for $78 I don't know would be funny on
Mars do you think aliens exist I'd love
to think that some sort of
extraterrestrial life exists I have a
feeling maybe maybe not on Mars I
wouldn't be surprised if there's like
some different form of life or some I'm
a carbon-based cell or something like
that another planet that's alive I
wouldn't be surprised
wouldn't be surprised if aliens exist
this is weird to call him an alien but I
wouldn't even aliens I do I believe
there's some other form of life out
there I think there has to be yeah
I agree if the universe is like ever
expanding I think that there's there's
no way there's not like at least
something yeah I mean how are we the
only ones I think it just doesn't make
sense unless this is all just like a
virtual yeah simulation I mean that's
the only thing I could think of is that
none nothing exists and everything is a
figment of our imagination and then
leads us to believe to each of us then
have our own realities like wow you
really exist is your reality completely
different than mine so am i potentially
all alone and everyone else is just a
figment of my imagination well as is
everybody else yeah it's crazy to think
so I don't know stuff I think about
every now and then we also have to
address the sad demise of dogecoin for
the record I sold out of it within 24
hours of buying into it I think I lost
but 50 bucks for you 50 thankfully I was
down yeah it was down and then I figured
ha man I was out to get the Pecos down
about $80 were you ever up no now one
moment as soon as they bought it you
it's the second I broke even for the
video basically the entire video
basically helped my loss and never in
the green it was not once again that is
so funny yeah I sold out for a loss of
like 60 bugs
so it didn't go my way I there it
doesn't only go up guys I know wasn't
gonna it's a stupid thing yeah there's
no point to it yeah for those of you
guys who are curious and worried about
me and my investments just know this is
all play money that I'm doing with like
you know the puts and the options and
dogecoin that's not like my retirement
my kids funds nope no it's all just play
money it's gambling money gambling
that's all you're doing yeah exactly
with dogecoin know the options IRS
options but yeah you told me today also
of Dave and Buster what happened there
man I don't want to talk about you don't
want to talk about it really I invested
in dave and buster's and of course the
California shut down again and I've been
holding onto the stock and it's been
going down consistently every month and
uh and I really believed in it and
then California announced they're gonna
be shutting down right now it's
indefinitely it's probably gonna be
about two weeks and I figured at that
point it's just like how much further
can dave and buster's really really go
from here if California is gonna be shut
down again if other places are gonna
begin shutting down again this is not a
stock to hold on to and I'm gonna put in
something safer so of course it's sold
out of it and then the next day goes up
20% 20% it goes up the day after I sold
it it's like and also the day that you
sold it it started climbing I started
going right after I sold it so it didn't
like me owning the stock what it is and
I said I rarely sell anything like the
the dogecoin I mean obvious I'm gonna
sell it but but yeah the Dave & Buster's
something like I'm holding on to
everything else that's the only one that
I've sold and of course it wasn't as
soon as I sell it yeah it seems like the
best investment strategy is just do the
opposite what yeah if Graham buys a
stock i shortlist on pretty much Warren
Buffett actually came today or there's
an announcement today that Warren
Buffett said he would have been so much
further ahead today if he just never
sold a stock Wow yeah that's incredible
yeah and then people say we'll win even
Cisco well if you still with Cisco what
about Hertz stock if you just never sell
the head stock so like just there's a
fine line there but I mean overall if
you just don't sell yeah you don't get
better off I've know in my actual
trading portfolio I've never sold
anything okay so yeah in my place stuff
like I do but that's a very small
percentage of that's the way it should
be ya know so there's what we do guys
well regarding the sell contract the
sell put contract that I talked about
last podcast it went through and
actually bought back with 90 minutes
left and I made like 46 dollars okay oh
so not too shabby I think I made like a
two percent return in one week nice so
things are still going well I'm two for
two on my options trading 24 20 that's
what we want what do you have for 20 for
20 is when it's funny it's what it takes
well I did another one this week and it
looks like it's gonna go in my favour
again good
so we three for three well every
right now is going up that's right now
yeah it's when things start going down
yeah so I think people are hopeful right
now for any sort of cure
mm-hmm and so they're just rallying and
stas all I'm saying is if I'm going
three for three I mean is that that's
better I'm guessing than you expect
that's better than two of two is that
what you expected I would do three out
of three
I don't know I don't know I did not give
that much thought hmm so if we can get
it 20 out of 20 then they don't they
don't listen to you okay all right all
right so now we're gonna go on a segment
where Graham is gonna review my budget
so I prepared my income and expenses and
I can throw up a screenshot of the
spreadsheet that's okay and Graham is
gonna look at all my stuff so I just
want to let you guys all know I was very
hesitant to do this because I don't
personally I don't like revealing this
information or it makes me feel a little
uncomfortable but I know you guys wanted
it okay so all right so here we go so we
got video editing 4,000 I want to read
this millennium item four thousand one
hundred and twenty seven dollars and
twenty-nine cents we got the mentorship
group link down below in the description
by the way you know what we should do
discount only here $30 off love it for
the first 10 people only mm-hmm let's do
it 30 bucks I'll go get to talk to
Graham and I oh yeah you could join the
livestreams yeah so yeah
$30 off first ten people down below in
the description if you want to join it
what it is is it's a it's a private
Ramsay I'm telling him about the
mentorship group it's what he does every
single time he wants attention yeah he
does that
Ramsey of telling you about the
mentorship group how they can you live
streams with me every Sunday morning at
9:00 a.m. Pacific Standard Time and then
a zoom call on Thursday at 5:00 p.m.
Pacific Standard Time and then you do it
Tuesday I do it on Tuesday yeah so uh so
yeah so the mentorship with eleven
hundred and six dollars a month hourly
okay six hundred dollars podcast a
hundred and forty four dollars and fifty
five cents okay
decent income that's good that's good
but then we got your expenses side
that's one mint with Matthew what's that
okay so that was that the that I got the
Vietnamese pho with my friend we're
spring rolls what's lucky groceries why
is it lucky I don't know that was what
meant classified it as I just got all
this from lucky PayPal don't know what
that was 1500 you paid you paid us that
one time with it for the drink
remember was it really yeah Oh or maybe
that was mo oh that was Ben no okay then
we got Little Caesars 539 okay that's
right two trees cafe $18.00 to the cafe
what was that I got this thing called a
Monte Cristo to sandwich my friends
wanted to go I forgot sprout sells okay
so Ralph's $140 that was groceries to
the month audible $15 a month fees and
charge what's why you think bees in
charge I have no idea what that was I
just saw you know what oh look at what
that is on mint because that's probably
like an overdraft of some sort
really yeah look at that I think it
wasn't over dry hair do some sort of
concealer you didn't pay a credit card
off in full on time or you got charged
interest on something it wasn't called
fees in charge it was called something
else and I was scared that it was
locational and I didn't want people to
know where exactly okay but it's it was
classified as a feat in the category all
right
jack-in-the-box 757 that's expensive for
jack-in-the-box yeah brochures 106 habit
Thompson for those venmo a dollar arc of
gas okay groceries she went to groceries
twice it's reading 220 dollars a month
in groceries yeah okay that's fine bonds
so gross 59 70809 total expenses 419
dollars that's a lot net income 55 my
expenses are a long a that's a lot of
money so okay so what I would do Ramsey
so what I would do is probably got to
cut out the little Caesars cut out the
tree two trees cafe get rid of those
fees and charges no jack-in-the-box you
want to get that down to like 380 a
month and I'd be happy
I spent 380 on the amp for July so I'm
already that's why I chose June instead
of July yeah Ramsey stop it he wants to
show you okay there you
I mean yes it's it's you got to get the
spending down disappointed a little bit
got to get the spending down a little
bit I mean it's it's good III
I mean obviously had no complaints on
this I mean overall it's not terrible
like I don't have very expensive taste
no for the most part it's good this
reminds me of my expenses back in the
day I would have like really nothing
yeah but I yeah it's good
yeah I'm fortunate I don't have very
expensive taste yeah you know I just
don't need very much to operate Graham I
maxed out my Roth IRA for 29 clappy
thing yellow where you do it there you
go
maxed out graduations thank you very
much nice
what do you invest in I invested in VT
Sachs Oh done easy so my own personal
investments I do Vikes
but in my Roth IRA I did VT Sachs
sparked yeah well congratulations that
that's the way to go
thank you so much eg Sachs it I was
perusing the internet and I found this
article called eight powerful personal
finance questions that you should ask
yourself so I thought it would be cool
if we asked ourselves these powerful
personal finance questions oh let's hear
it
number one what would you not do if you
could go back in time what would I not
do I would not I would not not get a
credit card no that's not I didn't get a
credit card so I would not not get a
credit okay alright
accounts that's a terrible answer what
would you not do invest in dogecoin so
Dave and Buster's um what would I not
everything is I would not not do this I
would I would have said I would not have
waited to set up a Roth IRA was like 22
I think I think I figured when you were
20 21 or 22 somewhere in there did you
just learn about it then yeah mmm yeah I
didn't max up my Roth IRA 2017 or 2018
yeah I learned about it when I was 21 22
somewhere around there okay so alright
that's fair
yeah so that's what I would not do I
would not wait okay not wait to do that
when do you picture your financial
independence day to be which is like
when you decide that you're good to to
just be free oh that was a few years ago
so already really
when did you just said it was I don't
think there's ever a decision it's just
it's just just happened it just happened
and I know properties I'm guessing well
yeah rental properties but it also like
I'm not talking about living you know
that it's it's called what is it called
like it's not like lean fire Oh in a way
it's lean fire so it's enough to pay all
my expenses and kind of everything I'd
want to do within reason but anything
over that then I'd have to save up and
invest more money but then you know
invest and save more money and then got
the house now and then had to invest and
save more money and got that covered so
I mean I'm not talking about like Lambos
or anything like that so that's the part
of me thinks like to be truly like fire
it would have to include all the
luxuries you could ever think of
so yeah so yeah what's your plan with
retirement are you ever gonna retire now
I doubt it I would be shocked how I ever
stopped yeah as you know there is I
always want to do something I like I
like working what's yours
my financial independent
oh probably I mean the worst financial
decisions I've ever made was probably
investing in Wells Fargo in General
Electric oh well as far as a terrible
company I threw some money and then yeah
cuz it figured like how much worse can
they be they got worse I mean I lost
money in Wells Fargo's stock so far it's
just a terrible company yeah I lost the
most money in Wells Fargo in general I
think they're both just bad investment I
agree but that is the worst financial
decision ever made all right the third
question we already answered which is
what would you do if you had ten million
dollars in the bank which your answer
would be the exact same thing if I had
10 million cash right now sitting in the
bank what I would do is probably take
half of it index funds half of it real
estate so they do
would you ever invest in bonds oh you
know what I actually started doing that
so I took two hundred thousand and I
bought California tax-free municipal
bonds yeah and there was like a pond
fund the advantage of that is that
income is not taxed at the state level
so it saves me on state income tax on
that what's the return I think after all
expenses and fees it's about 1.2 percent
but that's tax-free so that's really
more like 2.4 percent before taxes which
is big for me so I figured I may as well
throw some cash on that that it's always
gonna be there
tax-free and if I need the money it's
it's sitting there so I started doing
some other whatever yeah oh yeah it's an
index fund so you sell it and it's
available the next it's cool yeah what
would you do if you got 10 million
dollars we could ask you oh if I had 10
million dollars in the bank I
realistically I probably wouldn't be
editing videos I'd still I'm sorry all
right but the the labor of editing
videos I think could just be a scientist
like I could get someone else to do it I
would still I would love to still work
with you because I couldn't picture
myself doing anything else career-wise
so of course I still before that's a
good reason to drop out of college can't
do anything else I don't know I'd
probably buy a house and I would hate to
ever rent so I probably buy a house and
just chill go get some cool music
equipment all right that's fair you got
a jam yeah we do yeah this is a great
question I love this question what would
you do if you were not afraid of failure
not afraid of failure so you could still
fail it's just you're not afraid of
failing yeah but the whole idea of the
fact that you could still fail doesn't
apply in this situation because you just
wouldn't be afraid of it um gosh I would
say with all the stimulus stuff it's uh
all the stimulus stuff going around for
the first time ever my entire life I
started enjoying politics a little bit
at least following it so I don't know
maybe like I see people in the Senate
and it seems it seems interesting to me
to like run for a senator as something
like this is like I don't think I'll
ever do it but it least now seems a bit
interesting whereas before that would
never have crossed my mind
either that or sing about like maybe
starting a business but you know I just
could do that now not afraid of that
maybe something in politic I never
thought I'd ever say something polit
ever yeah but at least now I'm intro
in it so that's the only thing where
it's like oh it seems interesting I
don't know it's cool you get to make a
change yeah you could run for City
Council alright let's go let's go up
higher than that let's go well you have
to start somewhere exam senator you know
what I think would be interesting I
don't think I'm ever gonna do it but
running for president I I think would be
like I don't know again I would never do
it maybe it would never do but it's I
start watching these documentaries
unlike the White House it's like it's
really interesting stuff yeah like
really cool stuff the downside is that
you you have to have a college degree
like at least a bachelor's I don't god I
don't have that so I would need to get a
bachelor's degree is there no like
bachelors equivalent that you can have
maybe you should do it I mean look at
you you're charismatic you already have
like you've built up a I could probably
get away I could probably get a million
good primes in you could probably win I
don't know it but then it's like you're
you're in such a public I like that I
don't think you could ever return to a
normal life I just like having the
ability that if you ever want to
disappear for a little bit just lay low
you could do that you can't really do
that ever as a president's true but I
have a feeling at some point there's
gonna be a social-media influencer as a
president I think so because you got to
think it's like these people are
reaching you know 100 200 million people
every single month that's that's that's
basically you gotta be in a while though
because a lot of their audiences are
just younger because we grew up yeah but
you have to think too if someone's like
15 years old to 20 years old now
watching someone on YouTube and that
person 10 years from now they're still
they're still making YouTube videos and
they run for president and they trust
this person and they've been watching
them come up for 10 years that person
got their vote as long as they have a
good message and they're honest like
that they'd have my like if Elon Musk
were to run for president
instant vote right there a lot of people
would you vote for Elon yeah of course I
would I would love him to run for
president yeah I think the amount of
stuff you would get done and on a whim
he would wake up one morning and have a
crazy thought and be like okay let's
just make this a new law then yeah I
think he would be the most productive I
think he's too productive for that
like I I do think the downside of that
is it so much by bureaucracy you are and
and and there's a lot of stuff that you
just you don't have the wiggle room like
you look like Elon Musk of so much money
he could just choose to do whatever he
wants but when you're involved in that
you know it might be stifling yeah I
would totally vote for you on that would
be crazy
I wonder if that's ever I like I don't I
hope so but but yeah I do think I do you
think president would be kind of cool
I'm a dual citizen so believe or not I'm
also right so I would be I don't know
that has there been like I'd like a half
Canadian resident probably ya know I
think I'd be it could be the first half
Canadian president who has dual citizens
it's good that's a good angle yeah hit
it with be interesting yeah in for
president yeah pasul sort of laws would
be like okay we have smash the like
button day we have iced coffee Oh or
force everyone to watch Nova hilarious
the inauguration is just like what's up
you guys it's Graham here so thank you
guys so much for watching I really
appreciate and good your to free starts
down below oh my got this speech is
sponsored by up we help guys think about
that think of all the sponsors like you
get you get some good sponsor yeah yeah
oh my god I'd be given the speech
they'll be like but really quick you
could implement laws to force YouTube to
push your like yeah your favorite hope
you so much fun to be like alright guys
but really quick this is sponsored by a
trade coffee there's anything I love
more the trade it gets delivered to your
doorstep fresh from the roaster oh no
need to stand in line guys but no
seriously I think I think there will be
a social-media influencer president at
some point there has to be I wouldn't be
surprised
yeah you know if we got you know a movie
we got a movie actor I Ronald Reagan we
got Donald Trump you know did did some
TV I think it's just it's going in that
direction I think yeah like already
happening unlike an existing fan base
right exactly I think it's gonna take
probably 30 years to really start to see
that case
but I but yeah I'd say just give it time
would be fun to run though why don't you
do it it's like the I gotta get a
bachelors do you also have to be like 15
years older no I don't three five I
thought it's 40 35 minimum age to run
for president let me let me see I
remember this because I took I actually
paid attention to this in a history
class and I remember thing like 35 like
oh that's when I'm gonna run for
president 35 years old and have been a
resident United States for 14 years
let's see you later with let's see ok
current president requirements on hold
on offense natural-born citizen the
United States correct be at least 35
years old resident United States for 14
years most presidents of the United
States received a college education
however the US Constitution does not set
forth any education requirements for
presidents wait what are you serious
yeah that's according to thought code I
feel like if you really wanted to run
Prezi you probably go to college for
four years just like it wouldn't be that
big of a setback I was gonna run for
president but I'm gonna make a huge
change but then I realized I needed a
college degree
Oh Harry Truman never had a college
degree
well that's the thing too it's not a
good look to be like you know I was
gonna run for president put her to go to
college you should know it's too hard
yeah what it goes to show you I think a
college degree is not a requirement I
think I think it's a if anything it
shows that you're resourceful and you're
not gonna waste your time yeah you're
getting conventional norms socially just
because it's a requirement
you gotta question that you got a
question the system and you're like why
am I doing this what's the purpose of
this and this is gonna be how is that
going to benefit people and if it if not
a benefit to people and just seems like
a waste of time then you know I can do
it and and that could be applied to so
many other things with a lot of things
it's so hard for me to like to not
picture you giving a speech when you're
doing that like you just don't fit the
conventional norms and don't you fight
this international noisy system for all
the special like but needs an algorithm
and
oil prices have gone to highway I would
be so good for the stock market man yeah
I wanna see four I would I would
incentivize investments but so much I
would you honestly I I would make
financial education or require I would
treat honesty because in a way running
the country is a it's a business i I
think running it like a business but you
gotta be fair to people too so there's a
business is there some social issues we
gotta fix and some financial ones but I
would like at the core it's it's got to
make sense financially and we could we
got it we got to make sure that
everything is run efficiently yeah
that's what I really believe you got to
be fair to people too yeah so this is
great man you're just like a president
you're so presidential Graham fine man
you so giddy over me do it dude let me
see your kindness straight-up rotten kid
anyway I think you can at least run so I
mean I got another probably like eight
years to go so I could do what would
that be so we got you know twenty twenty
twenty twenty four twenty twenty eight
yeah would be the year where I can
you're gonna be up against like Kanye
West
just watch it be this one should be I'm
up against Elon Musk like at that point
I'll give it to Kanye did you at least
like I know my compensation million
votes because I mean think about your
YouTube channel
yeah but ten years in the future if I
have ten five millions Mainers
yeah yeah I mean gosh granny I don't
know what it would be like like that's
the thing like Justin well YouTube is
one of those things where I felt like I
could just try it out a little bit you
like it you keep going being president
is something you can't really just try
it out for a week or so humbly alright
guys I don't like it like I want to make
sure I enjoy it which is I make youtube
videos if you were president I'm so much
dude you could have crazy contacts like
you could you can set it the best office
in the world like you can release like
the laws on your YouTube channel before
you sign off on the papers it's like
buying new five stocks and buying
November
oh my god keep up with it think of the
thumbnails I had put on the on the
banners do something crazy man yeah
that's the interesting yeah yeah do it
man
let me be your vice president just be
how funny would it be if someone looks
back 20 years till they find the
podcaster like it started here like this
right here they're joking about it yeah
you know they're gonna take everything
out of context of course twist it
they're gonna villainize it but you get
recognized all the time if you're
president which would be tough you got
recognized today yeah that would happen
all the time yeah I wouldn't mind it I
wouldn't its intra it's food for thought
guys if you would vote for me let us
know I hit the like button mm-hmm and
every like button equals one night and
that's the thing too like I wouldn't I I
wouldn't like I I don't believe in
either side
yeah you too like I really don't take
sides I'm just like what makes sense for
each situation exactly dude if this
makes sense over here let's do that does
that make sense over there let's do that
once you subscribe to a side then you
have to you feel like you have to uphold
that sides agenda whatever it is when
you should be thinking independently and
for yourself and assessing each it like
situation as an individual case you know
I agree
take some presupposed like agenda no
that's what yeah I just everything take
everything in an edit its face value
this is the situation how do we best
navigate that with the resources we have
available the resources that we have
available yeah it's down so with that
said you guys ever ever see to that oh
thank you so much for watching as always
make sure to vote that's should I do do
kind stuff treat everyone with respect
you cancel Starbucks no more Starbucks I
did such a heavy tax yeah all right yeah
that's fine we'll see what big expenses
are on your five star horizon I don't
know what that means and how do you how
do you plan to save for them this
five-year horizon
what did I say five star horizons like I
don't know what that expenses five-year
horizon well the big the big expense was
B if I end up getting an office space so
to bring everyone up to speed
I've had this idea in my mind about
getting a house and then renovating the
whole house to be my office so I was
kind of thinking like a cool like
warehouse vibe with like garage doors on
the side and basically what I had in my
garage but I want like a larger space
like that I think it would be really
cool
so that would be wanted that's really
the only big expense mm-hmm everything
else is vol au equerry 'm would you save
for either of them or would you just be
like yeah it's time it's fun the
aquarium is something I told myself
August first I'm gonna make that
decision Wow so yeah so the aquarium is
really the only big thing maybe in
office
everything else is voluntary yeah what
about you big expenses on the horizon
I'm looking maybe getting an acoustic
guitar okay that's it oh yeah oh I love
this question okay what do you currently
own that you would not pay market value
for a lot of this furniture yeah yeah
why cuz did you get good deals on it no
wait what do I currently own that I
would not pay market value for I think a
more interesting question what did you
pay market value for furniture now you
would not wanna trip I love this
furniture in here but I I overpay it on
the furniture a lot of it's like was
custom done and it's really like it's
nice dude really high-quality stuff but
just get so much the table was this
thing right here don't understand what I
tell you much more mm more it's real
wood this is real wood and sands
movements and it's hand done this is
handmade it's not some sort of like
factory
handmade table real wood and and it's to
match this to 2500 more you're saying it
with such conviction
oh this table dad this day let's say I
wasn't what six thousand lesson
about $5,500 for the for a dining table
now my mentality of it was that this is
like the best quality wood that's
handmade and this is something that will
last decades like this is not meant to
be a table you buy like you know you get
and then you toss it out after a while
like you keep this table for a very long
time this is like multi-decade so I
figured like you get four nice furniture
once and then you never need to replace
the furniture ever again but it's the
same table honestly like at its core
it's like I would be just fine with it
that's not kidding I never said anything
but I the first time I saw and touched
this table very nice like oh yeah I
could tell it was a nice table but I
didn't know it was real and everything
real and hand done this whole I mean it
looks beautiful
yeah and now maybe you could even use it
as a write-off yeah I mean this is
something where someone actually came
into the measurements and then measured
it precisely to this day they bound
themselves down to the inch handmade
this was all hand done this is like a
really good fabric that's that's meant
to withstand like like stains and
everything like that so it's all it's
really nice but it's not something where
I would I personally would feel better
having spent like $1,500 for like a nice
table and get ninety percent the same
thing then spent so much more for that
extra 10 percent yeah this is a 10 at a
10 table though yeah it's a beautiful
table yeah thanks I personally I don't
think I have anything really like a lot
of my clothes I guess it would be closed
because I have clothes that are of
decent quality but honestly a lot of it
was just hand-me-downs because I have an
older brother and like older family
friends and they would just give it to
my brother and then to me growing up so
it's like nice it's $20 shirts right but
if I were buying my own clothing
I would buy like $3 shirts I would go to
thrift stores hmm makes sense
I should really here enough fair like
makes sense yeah do you think you're
gonna stick with your current habits for
the rest of your life probably really
you don't think that there's ever gonna
be a time realistically that you're
gonna start splurging a little bit no
this age I mean I've got my entire life
without doing that so even if you
started making 10 million dollars a year
you wouldn't really be
spending much more than reason when when
do you enjoy your money though all the
time going out last night yeah sure I
treat I treated Jack and Macey for
dinner it was really good ago yeah thank
you very much come on I'll come got
ramen you're welcome we common got ramen
and good sushi wet yeah stuff like that
you know that's fine that that's that
that's me enjoying my money me too yeah
yeah you're enjoying yeah I saw a
comment on one of your videos and said
they asked what your opinions on a
prenup one huh and I assumed what they
were but I want to hear what they are
from yeah I think it makes sense I think
you're basically in a marriage
bringing a business contract into it and
you wouldn't start a business without
having a contract first
especially with it with with two people
who are involved emotionally and I think
combining business with emotion is not
generally a good idea and it's like
having insurance is the way I kind of
think about it you have car insurance
never expecting to be in an accident but
if something happens we have insurance
and I think a prenuptial agreement will
the very least set the expectations when
things are good that if something is to
happen and nobody wants anything to
happen but if something does what are
the expectations going forward from that
and I think it just protects everybody
and it just clears up any any confusion
because otherwise what happens is you
leave it up to the state to decide I
think it's a lot more powerful to leave
that decision to two people to come
together and have an agreement than it
is to leave it to chance and leave it to
the state I think you can never be too
careful right so I think it's always
smart to err on the side of caution and
I totally yeah I think it should be I
mean I personally I'm gonna do it and I
think that it's a wise decision for
everyone to make is to write a prenup
yeah I think so too and again you never
go in and some people say well are you
going with you expectation you know you
just you don't even one thing but it's
like you you never go into the
expectation ever I'm sure most people
that get married never go in with the
expectation that like something could
happen you never want that to happen and
I'm certainly one of those people like
like you know whatever I get married I
want that to be
forever I mean I really don't I wouldn't
I would hate to have to go through
something like that so it's just a
precaution but you never intend to use
it um so there's a lot a lot of
analogies you could use like that but
it's yeah I think that you know when you
mix something that's like business which
is a very rational thing it's very like
it's a one total like way of thinking
right like logical and rational and you
make something that's that's like
relationship which is purely emotional
integrity emotional is the exact
opposite of rational yeah you know so
mixing those two can be a very dangerous
situation so I just English I really
don't see any downside we'll put it that
way I don't think there's any negative
yeah yeah um I guess we could I mean if
I have two gmail questions we can go
over go for it yeah I know you own
several rental properties and I'm pretty
sure they're all in California would you
ever consider any rental properties out
of state and if so what are some that
you're looking at yeah I definitely
would I just don't know the properties
is well out of state the only the only
area I was looking in was Phoenix it
just it seems like a really good area I
like Arizona in general it's kind of
close to California good property values
good rental values it seems like a good
mix of everything so would consider it
at the right time maybe not right now
maybe right now but Phoenix at Nashville
also looks pretty cool but I've never
been to Nashville just from what I've
seen online you think the future of
college education will be like a lot of
universities have moved online and I've
been seeing a lot of people asking for
tuition cuts or deciding that if classes
I think it's this is a good catalyst for
people not to go to college first of all
two things one for the cost of college
to go down if they could teach class
online why don't they just have a
pre-recorded class that anyone can take
at any time someone could log in at any
age and basically be like okay 12:00
p.m. I'm gonna watch this lecture that
was given last year
and people do the same thing as Tai
Lopez was doing a few years ago just
record something once give it to a whole
bunch of people who need it charge a
flat fee and then give a quiz at the
very end that like there's an actual
person going and grading it then have
that person available maybe for
discussion over zoom or something like
that and then had that person available
for like email or chat exchanges or
whatever I don't know if it's gonna be
the same it's not gonna be the same
experience I think is going in person I
think there's something to be said about
meeting in person
it cannot be replaced at all with zoom
calls I think it would be a really smart
thing to have it online because then
everybody will be able to go their own
pace and I feel like it's it's very
similar to the whole analogy of like the
the sleigh is only gonna go as fast as
the slowest huskier when I are dragging
the sleigh it's because if you're in
class the speed of the class is gonna go
at the speed of the slowest person you
know I mean like the people that are
learning this stuff extremely quickly
there they're gonna be slowed down by
the people around so if you could go
you're on speed and everything can be
online that'd be great but I've been
noticing on the the UCSB or the my
colleges reddit page I noticed that a
lot of people are saying like they're
considering dropping out of school
because yeah of the whole kind I get it
again it you thinking about dropping out
of school no no I'm not thinking about
it I'm just saying a lot of people are
saying that I know here's here's where
it gets interesting let's say the Ivy
League schools like Harvard and Yale
start having posting your classes up
online like that who's to say it's
someone else can't just go and take
their classes online let's say they're
pre-recorded you know to reach a hundred
people they could easily reach a hundred
thousand people they 50,000 people then
we're like tuition right but but then
where would the benefit be who's to say
let's say I have a course and I say only
people who pass a test can take my
course who's to say who could dig a
course new can't colleges don't want you
to think like this it psychologist
didn't want you to know about this yeah
it's really it's so stupid I think I
think people are finally catching on to
colleges I think a waste of time it's
overpriced so one I think this is going
to help bring the cost of college down
colleges don't need the
cost they don't yeah even though it's
online my fall quarter is the exact same
price as [ __ ] eBay scores I've done and
I'm still paying fees for stuff like
recreational fees for like a rec center
that's not even oh yeah I mean I would
say the only benefit to college is to
meet like-minded people who by the way
you might not meet like-minded people
might be just going and partying at some
some frat house I mean it might be that
but I think the only benefit is as
social experiments it's so so a social
experience I think so many YouTube
videos social experiments that's social
experience
I think is the only benefit to going to
college and it's a and it can be a good
Segway in between living with your
parents and trying to be an adult I mean
that that's the only benefit but you're
paying an extraordinary amount of money
for that experience that you could get
on you're like imagine paying $40,000 a
year for a school or 30,000 for that you
could have your own little apartment
with two or three people and just be an
adult and make money being adults being
adults just grow up just drop out and be
you know don't act stupid you're that
stupid being adults grow up get a job
you're done you're real person seriously
just be an actual living person
yeah human being yeah don't go to school
stuff acting stupid
yeah guys duh be smart and don't go to
college
yeah be smart and drugs just it's
ridiculous I think the cost of college
will need to go down if they offer it
online then there goes their whole
business model their business model was
not adapted to go online where anybody
could log in at any time and take a
class I don't know if colleges are gonna
change but I think people are realizing
how ridiculous it is at least in this
time right now all the courses being
online pre-recorded lectures you know
people are realizing it's essentially
the same exact thing yeah and it's
costing the same amount as in class and
we can do it at home
ya know we an hour in speed yeah I've
said it before I took a while ago that
Tai Lopez online thing and I went
through it and I really believed that
like that was better information than
most people would learn in school and I
think it was I forget how much it was I
think it was like a monthly thing
or something like that but it was it was
it was good for the costs a lot of
people give him crap for that but I don
ously think for the cost if someone's
gonna spend $500 they're gonna get a
better education from that in college
all things considered I don't honestly I
don't necessarily disagree with that no
one does all right
Harvard does all right so with that said
you guys thank you so much for watching
thank you road for this awesome
equipment I said it sounds amazing
Graham yeah make sure to get your two
free stocks down below in the
description weeble is gonna be giving
you two pre stocks when you deposit $100
if one of the stocks valued all the way
to $1400 so if you want e to free stocks
use that link down below the mentorship
group is also down below like I said $30
off for the first ten people so I'll put
that link down below in the description
what else is there it's like button
smash it destroy it a strong like button
vote for Graham we're done oh thanks
guys really appreciate it and done until
next next time see ya
nice there we go I'll put this here and
whoa ha
voila